we're talking about how a lot of times
you know certain things like food can
obviously do certain things within the
body but then there's of course fitness
and then there's like what you do
um workout wise i mean see i used to
think of the body as being like
having multiple systems i'm like oh i go
do upper body workout my lower body's
not sore i'll kill that today and then
i'll go do and then i'll go crush it and
have do a bunch of interviews and crank
my brain and really think and be focused
and so i used to think of my body as
having these multiple systems and i
could just rotate through tapping them
and kind of as time has gone and i've
gone through my health
you know struggles and journey and you
know i feel good so it's not like i
there's a lot of people in a worse
position than i am but i want optimal
and um
and i've ended up realizing wow the
whole body is like one motherboard
system and i learned a lot of this
through training for the boston marathon
this year um
which was brutal in arizona um
especially when you have to run in the
summer yeah i think um the l.a marathon
when i lived in arizona as well oh gosh
brutal brutal i'm so sorry i had all the
empathy you could possibly need right
here
um but i i ended up starting to realize
how you know just heat in and of itself
is an element and then you know the the
the volume of the running versus the
resting and you could see how your heart
rate variability changes you can see how
your recovery changes and you could just
see and especially my functional doctors
like you want to heal all these things
but you're running a marathon like
you're really being hard on your body so
you know maybe we could talk just help
us understand you know what what happens
to the body when we over train because
i'm i'm i'm i'm totally guilty of that
yeah
i mean sounds like there
may have been over training but sounds
like you had over life training
going on at the same time so it's hard
to say if you were over training or if
you just had other stressors that were
making the over training more evident
so what are those stressors because
that's the thing is that they all matter
like they all are part of the same
system and i think in functional
medicine that's what i've ended up
realizing is like there's an overlap of
like like everything kind of works
together and it's like one's down the
other's off and it's like it's just
really really delicate balance and um
and so maybe explaining just kind of
what are the what are all of the
draining buckets because i think there's
somebody that goes to work and they're
you know working their butt off all day
and then they come home and they have
stress and they're trying to get their
work out and they're doing this and it's
like they can't figure out why they
can't lose weight
yeah it goes back to
the main overarching thing we talked
about intermittent fasting on how your
body needs that buildup needs the
breakdown like you can't have one or the
other and if you are
getting the teardown of the stressors
happening non-stop where you're tearing
down your muscles so you don't actually
um have any type of recovery from your
muscles but then you also are getting a
lot of mental stress which acts
physically within our body the mental
stress causes the same type of stressors
to be signaled within our body so our
body perceives it still as a stress
especially if you're um you know
operating at a higher level and have a
lot of stress with your job but then
also if you're not getting great sleep
that's other that's a huge factor that's
usually the biggest one where you can
work at a pretty high intensity with
your workouts and a pretty high
intensity with your job as long as
you're getting sleep and as long as
you're eating the right types of foods
but if you're not getting the sleep
that's our master recovery area and if
you're not getting the right type of
sleep
then it doesn't matter if you're not
over training it doesn't matter if
you're not stressed at work you're going
to be in that stress state from a lack
of sleep so i don't know if
from your perspective it seemed like
maybe the sleep resonated a little with
you um
actually i sleep really well
i actually sleep just fine i'm like i
tap the buckets like i'm one of those
people that's just like just
i am all about it and if i'm bored i
just go work out
yeah yeah yeah then you probably just
were overdoing it with both because
there's most people i mean you're a
little bit of a different case where you
probably just were really actually
pushing yourself to the extremes on both
work and um your exercise routine
but a lot of people don't consider sleep
so probably a lot of your listeners
don't actually get the sleep they need
to recover from those workouts or to
recover from the stress of work and
people will be amazed if they cut out
the one hour of netflix and chill and
added that to their sleep on how much
that would make them feel better the
next day i mean poor sleep increases
your stress hormone increases your
hunger hormone ghrelin the next day it
increases insulin resistance which makes
it harder to actually tap into fat
burning um so there's a lot of negative
things that happen when you sleep that
make it so that you also can't recover
because if you have a higher cortisol
higher stress level state your body
isn't in that rest and repair mode it's
in that fight-or-flight mode so you're
always going to be in that restroom
impaired never in or always in that
fight or flight never in that rest of
repair to recover from the stressors of
the day
do we really have to stop the chill i
mean with the next flicks and chill like
i feel like the chill probably has some
really good hormonal benefits yeah yeah
the chill part totally um the negative
is you're just looking at a light and
it's totally destroying your melatonin
production which is our sleep hormone
and so wait i thought that meant sex
sorry
let's get rid of the netflix part just
jump to the chill part and that's
perfect what are the benefits of the
chill part i mean are there like is
there what are the sexual like with sex
what hormones are triggered and is it
good to do it before you go to bed i
mean does it help you sleep or what what
are the honestly that's not my area of
expertise
um if we we could talk about food and
hormones all day long uh i think it
depends on the individual and if it
hypes them up or not but you know it
seems like a great option chill do it
just not too much netflix got it not too
much netflix don't know that part have
the chill part
um well one topic that i think i you
know is i feel like is so beneficial and
i was reminded
recently going to new york and walking
like 12 miles one day and that's all i
did that day like we just went there and
we just walked around the park
and went shopping and it was just like
the mother of all walking days and i
just forget how like good you feel and
it's one of those things that you can do
and do and do and the body tolerates it
so well and even from an experiential
standpoint when i wore the continued
blood blood gluco us blood glucose
monitor is that
when i'd start walking
my blood sugar would drop
yeah um it goes down to the couple
factors so obviously it's lower
intensity so you're not using the
glucose as a fuel source you're
switching into using baddest build so
when your heart rate's lower which it is
when you're walking you're using fat
primarily and that is such a sustainable
energy source we have so much fat to tap
into even if you're extremely lean even
if you have 10 body fat or lower you
have so much fat that you can use versus
two hours worth of carbohydrates that
you can use that are stored in your body
so um just by switching over to that
that's really great from that
perspective but also hormonally i mean
you said you're walking around the park
you're walking outside and walking
outside specifically you know exposes us
to something called negative ions which
has been found to decrease our serum
cortisol levels which are stress hormone
and remember cortisol raises blood
glucose so if we can decrease cortisol
we decrease stress but we also decrease
the blood glucose level as well
wow so what i mean
explain more of the science of it
because like if you're
you know what does it do what is it
doing to you when you take a walk versus
when you go into the gym and hit the
weights
well first of all when you take a walk
you can do it more frequently like you
can get up i have a fitbit i get up
every hour when my fitbit tells me i
have not gotten 250 steps for that hour
and i walk around in place like
anyone who has a fitbit definitely gets
that annoying reminder but it's so good
because you can do it frequently whereas
training you can't you can't like lift
weights every hour you can walk every
hour and that breaks up sedentary
moments throughout the day even if it's
just for one minute that you're getting
up and walking around you're getting
your muscles flexing you're getting your
muscles actually using energy which
makes the body more insulin sensitive
and helps it more easily burn fat as
fuel as a result too so just from a
purely practical perspective like you
mentioned you could walk all day or even
if you don't have the opportunity to
walk you know 14 miles through the park
on a beautiful new york day anyone can
get up from their desk and stand for one
minute and walk around their office it's
just such a practical approach to
keeping insulin sensitivity high and
getting the body moving so that you're
actually contracting your muscles um and
using fat as fuel the process if you
were to put into
words your ideal day and your ideal week
like how would that look from your
perspective
uh do you mean like just from exercise
yeah like exercise nutrition fasting you
know does and and then also do you and
then maybe especially i'm just so
curious from a female perspective
because so many somebody there's such a
lack of studies done on women
um like is there a certain time in the
month where you would be more apt to do
some more of one thing or less of
another
yeah um well just for a regular day i
mean typically i wake up the first thing
i do is i go for a walk because that
helps to get your body actually moving
obviously you get your insulin
sensitivity higher um you get to use fat
as fuel when your body is most primed to
be using fattest fuel and personally
just wakes me up right away so do that
completely fasted um and then i always
come back and do strength training
workout right after that still during
the completely fasted state
to maximize all those growth hormone
benefits um and then i personally use
keto coffee i can't do black coffee i
love keto coffee so i stick with that
route and i transition into more of a
fasting mimicking state around like
eight or nine a.m and then totally break
my fast anywhere between
10 a.m to noon really depends on five
clients that day or if i'm just filming
i always break my fast with protein fat
and fiber so it's usually going to be a
smoothie that has greek yogurt protein
powder chia seeds peanut butter
using coconut milk a low sugar fruit
like a small amount of berries um
strawberries raspberries
and then all i typically personally use
a three meal structure i just found like
if i do two meals i'm way too hungry
like i just can't do it so i have a
three meal structure not snacking
between just having water
having sea salt
i also use apple cider vinegar before i
break my fast to help stabilize blood
glucose levels before the first meal
um
and then my second meal usually like
scrambled eggs eggs are one of the best
protein sources it's so bioavailable
it's the most bioavailable protein um
and also rich in fat so it's like an
easy one where you don't have to over
complicate adding in all these
ingredients
and then personally for myself for
dinner usually on 6 pm and um i'm going
to be i mean
i have i like to make recipes i love to
cook
so it's
all across the board like beef stew
burgers something along those lines um
and take my magnesium go to bed and
repeat it the next day